SPEAKER_01: Paul, you're late again.
SPEAKER_00: Sorry, I never get up before 8.45.
SPEAKER_01: 8.45? That's late.
SPEAKER_00: What time do you get up?
SPEAKER_00: 5 a.m.
SPEAKER_00: 5 a.m.? That's early. What do you do in the morning?
SPEAKER_01: Well, after I get up, I usually make breakfast,
SPEAKER_01: take out the garbage, do the laundry.
SPEAKER_00: The laundry?
SPEAKER_01: Yes. Then I read the newspaper, check my email.
SPEAKER_01: Sometimes I take a nap.
SPEAKER_00: You take a nap in the morning?
SPEAKER_01: Just 15 minutes.
SPEAKER_01: On Monday, Wednesday, and Friday I exercise,
SPEAKER_01: and on the other days I clean the house.
SPEAKER_01: Then I take a shower, get dressed, put on my makeup, and go to work.
SPEAKER_00: Wow. You never sleep late?
SPEAKER_00: On the weekends, I sleep till 6.
SPEAKER_00: That's really good. You do laundry in the morning?
SPEAKER_01: And the evening. Why? When do you do the laundry?
SPEAKER_00: Usually in March. And September.